kitchen fires Clark County Fire says
Thanksgiving Christmas are often their
busiest days because of cooking fires
Candace Charles is live in the studio
kitchen right now not setting it on fire
but instead showing us some important
safety tips Candace good morning to you
well John I'm hoping to avoid some of
those things as an example for you guys
okay so you've got the fire extinguisher
on the side you checked your fire alarms
and you're making sure to keep the kids
out of the kitchen now these seem like
simple and Common Sense things for you
to do when you're cooking your holiday
dinner but sometimes people forget and
really that distinction can help keep
you and your family safe when you do
your holiday cooking now this is a
simple warning from the fire officials
at Clark County if you're going to fry a
turkey yes do it outside but don't have
your fryer popped on anything don't
throw your turkey in the oil and
certainly dress appropriately I know you
guys saw my beautiful long sleeves
probably not a good idea when you're
cooking now if you're staying in the
kitchen please don't leave your food
undetended fires aren't the only risk
you face when cooking germs that can
make you sick survive in many places are
around your kitchen including food of
course your hands utensils cutting
boards and countertops so wash your
hands I'm gonna say this again for you
guys wash your hands utensils cutting
boards countertops all of these things
before and after you go around cooking
in your kitchen now believe it or not
you don't need to wash your turkey CC
sets that's not necessarily necessary
yet again one of the biggest research
concerns and one of the biggest reasons
people go for the hospital during
Thanksgiving are cooking fires
they're they're very preventable
we just want to make sure people are
taking Common Sense steps to reduce the
risk of getting injured such as making
sure your smoke alarms are working
making sure if you're cooking anything
in the kitchen to make sure that it is
supervised because it just takes a few
seconds and the fire can erupt
certainly so this year alone the red
cars of Southern Nevada has responded to
nearly 60 Home Fires now you don't want
to join that list so beyond the fires as
we mentioned have your different
utensils as well as your cutting boards
for your cooking to make sure you don't
have cross contamination again keep your
eye on all your food in your kitchen
don't leave things unattended and keep
that fire extinguisher nearby